[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein ganz klassisches
rezept wir werden marillenknödel machen
also aprikosen knödel
ich musste mich gerade nochmal
vergewissern was der unterschied
zwischen aprikosen und maschinen ist der
unterschied ist dass der österreicher
einfach mir hat mein marille sagen und
die deutschen aprikose und dann gibt es
noch die mirabelle und dass es wieder
was anderes desto mehr so kleine flammen
und ich habe mein obst premiere aprikose
mirabelle mischung
ich bin völlig durcheinander jedenfalls
werden wir dieses leckere dessert
zubereiten
in österreich habe ich schon gegessen
man kann das ganze auch mit erdbeeren
zum beispiel machen zur erdbeerzeit oder
auch anderes obst verwenden heute gibt
es die aber mit aprikosen und
traditionell werden dann die aprikosen
entscheidend und dann kommt da ein
würfelzucker rein ich mache aber keinen
würfelzucker rein sondern
marzipanrohmasse dafür verwende ich also
für die füllung etwas marzipanrohmasse
hier habe ich aprikosen dann brauche ich
für den teig 2 1 500 gramm quark oder
tropfen 150 g weiche butter etwas
vanille extrakt 400 gramm mehl und eine
prise salz und später dann zum drin
wälzen nochmal etwas butter semmelbrösel
und etwas zimt bei der marzipanrohmasse
könnt ihr entscheiden ob ihr die pur
nehmt oder ob ihr geschmackliche
variationen nimmt ich hab hier einmal
heavenly creatures dann gibt es die
geschmacksrichtung amaretto sanddorn
orange da dürft ihr einfach selbst
entscheiden das ist auch das erste was
ich machen werde
das heißt die aprikose aufschlitzen
ich mach dir auch nicht als ich
halbierte nicht sondern ich mache nur in
schlitz brennt neben den kern raus und
da kann ich dann gleich marzipan
eingeben und wenn ihr kein markt erlebt
macht halt ganz klassisch und steckten
würfelzucker rein so kommt einfach noch
ein bisschen süße betreiben und vor
allem habe ich ja im teig keinen zucker
also darf die aprikose ruhig ein
bisschen süße haben
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt heavenly marzipan mit
man durch stückchen und jetzt nehme ich
das einfach so ungefähr im kern größe
egal ich krieg das hier rein oder nee
ich muss schon kerngröße das was
rausgeht muss dann halt danach wieder
und dann einfach bisschen zusammenrücken
durch die masse hält auch schon zusammen
[Musik]
also da wo stellen wird definitiv um es
in jörgs worten auszudrücken safe würde
ich da noch machen
es war schon deine wortwahl
vielleicht vielleicht dave rich das sagt
schon nice amazon partnerschaft auch
mein favorit ist schon ich bin da immer
so in den lämmern oder november an oder
nougat und an der bar beides einfach
beides nicht schreiben der zuschauer die
uns auch schon lange folgt und
kommentiert schrieb sie sie kann keinen
lukas sehen und dann hab ich kein motto
wenn du unter null grad probierstand
erst mal 123 kommentiert immer viel
vielen dank dass ihr schaut sich
bestimmt auch dieses video hat man dann
sieht sie dass ich sie geprüft haben
[Musik]
für den teig gebe ich jetzt die eier in
der rührschüssel das ist ein ganz
schneller quark butter teig und da muss
man auch großartig nichts beachten außer
dass einfach die butterweich ist damit
sie sich wirklich schön verbindet so in
deutschland heißt quark in österreich
topfen die weiche butter dazu bisschen
man extrakt und dann kommt jetzt hier
noch das mehl dazu mit dem salz
unterteilt wird einfach kurz gebunden
bisher schön homogen ist
[Musik]
das waren schon das war es schon los ich
hole jetzt direkt mal den topf und ein
schneidebrett den bug matte ich finde
das war wie im film ich kam mit meinem
arm auf diesen löffel und das habt ihr
alles bon geschossen
[Musik]
warum aber rasch
von sandra smisek staubsauger da
rausgeholt
das hat also das wasser mache ich jetzt
schon einmal an dann und bislang
[Musik]
vielleicht auch ein bisschen drauf
jetzt eine rolle formen sagt jetzt ein
teil wenn nicht einfacher
[Musik]
was auch richtig gut kommt denke ich im
teig ist muss bisher zitronen april bis
juni also ich hab ich mal die ganze bank
matten breite ausgenutzt und 40
zentimetern
ich habe zehn aprikosen also mache ich
immer nach 4 cm einen quatsch also schön
die viererreihe 48 12 16 20 und 24 28 32
36 40 meist new york das ist nicht nur
einfach kochen hier das ist auch bisher
in mathe manchmal für sie manchmal das
nehmt ihr euch hier so ein bisschen der
teig also eine portion öffnet sie in der
handfläche zu einem kreis liegt die
gefühlte aprikose hinein oder andere
obst was ihr habt und verschließt schön
gleichmäßig wenn es ein bisschen klebt
bisschen mail an die hände nehmen und
dann verschließen wir schon gebuchte
und wenn ihr jetzt kleineres obst habt
kann dadurch sein dass sie einfach
bisschen weniger teilnimmt und eben
mehrere portionen und raus bekommt aber
größer als eine aprikose war schon
ziemlich groß eine melone
nehmen wir die komplette portion bitte
nicht bitte macht nicht wo mein gott
melonen knödel
wow guck mal wie schön sie so ein
schneeball
[Musik]
also ich habe jetzt hier schon parallel
wasser aufgesetzt
ohne salz ohne alles einfach zu kochen
gebracht
hier stelle ich jetzt ein bisschen
runter denn kochen soll sich nicht
sondern nur 7
und was ich hier noch machen werde ist
ich habe hier schon beschichtete pfanne
da kommt die restliche butter rein die
die nicht in den teig gehörte die kamera
auch schon mal zu lassen
dem darin wird es später dann nochmal so
geschwenkt mit denen die mutter mit dem
brot krümelchen und jetzt hier das war
vor unterstellen ist halt echt auch ein
schnelles rezept also wenn ihr das mal
so als nachtisch machen wird schon gut
ich gucke jetzt dass ich es vorher noch
mal schön runter rolle und dann wirklich
nur sieben lassen
die brauchen dann so 10 12 minuten die
aprikosen sollen ja auch schön weich
werden
[Musik]
ich gebe es hier aber nur fünf
gleichzeitig ins wasser weil es
ansonsten echt zu viel wird ihr könnt ja
auch mit zwei töpfen arbeiten und jetzt
wirklich so 10 12 bis 15 minuten ziehen
lassen und die schwimmen dann auch
gleich oben wenn sie fertig sind in der
zwischenzeit schmilzt hier schon die
butter und ich kann auch hier gleich die
semmelbrösel mit dem zimt dazugeben und
einfach schon mal vorbereiten und hier
drinnen lassen also so ein bisschen
anrösten und nachdem sie den kommen die
nämlich direkt hier
[Musik]
und in der zwischenzeit einfach weiter
rolle guckt mal hat der eine der
schwimmt jetzt schon oben da ist jetzt
gar und die anderen die kommen jetzt
gleich nach oben
alle nacheinander
[Musik]
jetzt sind die marillenknödel fertig und
dann habt ihr sie heraus dann kommen sie
in die mischung aus schlager und dann
auf einen teller und da das rezept so
schnell geht probieren wir es auch
direkt sarah seid ihr bereit und nimmt
ihr besteck wird und eigentlich passt da
was passt gut dazu sagen wir ja
naja also auf den teller für mich und
ihr seht auf die semmelbrösel die sind
jetzt schön gebräunt falsche kamera und
ihr seht jetzt auch die semmelbrösel die
sinne schön gebräunt
wir mussten jetzt mit stativ weil der
jetzt hier probiert dann ist irgendwann
habe ich das foto hier
ok dann brauchen wir noch einen teller
und guck doch mal hier einfach so wissel
schwenken
danke dass ich hoffe mal diese so
praktisch hier reinkommen und dann
einfach so schwenkten schenken
professionell sind knödel in die pfanne
schwenken komplett verrückt okay ich
mache jetzt alle hier rein und wir
können vielleicht ein probieren und dann
nehmen die anderen für die fotos oder
naja das so ja oder also manchmal wird
sie für die fotos trocken und warum
haben wir dann und dann kam der junge
mit der idee
oh mein gott und daran stoff ausflippen
dass wir die knödel auch mal frittieren
müssen die tiere frei
wir wollen ja mal freaky friday machen
und wollen einfach friedlich
das heißt soll ich jetzt noch backen und
können sie schon aber wir haben heute
keine zeit mehr das macht es so wir
probieren die jetzt beenden das video
und wenn wir morgen früh zeit haben
machen wir das gleiche nochmal und
frittieren die noch und dann hängen uns
mit einem wieder dran
ja das problem mal ausziehen und können
wir dann auch nougat rein machen und
beim frittieren ein eigenständiges video
jetzt nimmt es ausnahme sein ziel
also jetzt hab dich hier so ein knödel
und dann nehmt ihr einfach als und
vanillesoße perfekt dazu marmelade
perfekt in der mitte ist mama ist
[Musik]
maximal nur mein marzipan am messer dass
du hierbleiben darum geht es ja ja wir
essen seitz gleich acht mal so vielen
dank und dann so ich muss ganz
unanständig einfach aus der hand essen
ja ich glaube das geht nicht wenn die
hand ist machen wir das auch wie das so
ist darüber und dann die macht ergreifen
süßer schnee egal was schmeckt so lecker
ich brauch nicht schmeckt so lecker denn
es ist gar nicht süß im teig ist kein
zucker nur in marzipan ist bisschen
zucker ab ich hab ein ganz toll mal mit
viel mantel anteil
das heißt die süße kommt ein echter
inzwischen stehen oder durch die soße
ich wollte es gerade sagen es schmeckt
leicht fällt nichts ein
das wirklich mit einfach mega leverkusen
was ist der unterschied maria seien
österreicher und bayern und deutschland
sagte aprikosen aprikose und das warme
der warmen raum ein echtes wenn es noch
warm ist wie man jetzt noch dabei macht
uns dann zitiert mit der nun aber ist
das auch gut dazu schmecken vanilleeis
vanilleeis und dann ruhig und so wandte
als sohn knödel ich habe nur noch frau
nie eins in deutschland
werden wir sind beim lukas kubis und
lecker sich gut verstehen findet ihr das
verhältnis teig zur erfüllung gut man
kann es auch dünner
also ich finde ich denn den teig dünner
bisschen besser
ich hatte jetzt am schluss noch zu viel
ich glaube wenn man dort am luca drauf
ich glaube aus der menge gut wenn man es
mit beilage ist somit soester finde ich
im bett wenn man sie so solo lässt finde
ich kann man aus der menge zwölf bis
vierzehn schnitt machen und dann hat man
einfach einen dünneren teig over lecker
das war ein gutes frühstück
also schreibt mir doch mal gerne ob ihr
schon mal marillenknödel aprikosen
knödel gegessen habt was eure lieblings
füllung ist okay wenn es machen würde
das mindestens machen wenn ihr also
wieso sie wieder zurück war knödel und
schreibt probier s mal ausprobieren
werdet und ich sage euch das schmeckt
echt hammer und lecker oh mein gott und
die frittierte version
ich weiß nicht vielleicht hängen was ich
noch hinten dran auf jeden fall wir
entscheiden morgen früheren wir morgen
früh 2
also viel spaß beim nachmachen uns in
guten appetit ich freue mich so richtig
da noch mal eine davon zu essen und dann
sehen wir uns nächstes mal wieder
[Musik]